Speaker 1: Let's go to the voicemails. You
can call me any time. And many do call it very
strange times during which I'm typically
sleeping at two one nine two David P..
I do have 600 voicemails to to triage from the
long weekend. I'm working on it. But here is one
asking about whether I speak an additional
language. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: Hi, David. Hello, sir. I'm wondering
whether or not your family speaks Judeo Espanol
or Latino. This is a dying Sephardic language.
I myself in the society, too. I was wondering
whether or not your family, especially because
they speak Spanish, is is a family that speaks
this. I'm the first in my family in 500 years to
not speak it fluently. My family are Turkish news,
which most people don't know exists. But there is
a population of Jewish folks in Turkey and we were
accepted by the Sultan visit the second after the
Inquisition. He famously told Queen Isabella and
King Ferdinand what you consider to be garbage we
consider to be treasure. Well accepted by family.
Speaker 1: OK, you know, my family is
not Sephardic and we do not speak Ladino
or Judeo. Spanish. Yeah, being
Ashkenazi and being born in Argentina,
we just spoke Spanish. That's it. But a
fascinating language. A fascinating language. And
I can I'm glad to give a list of the languages I
don't speak. It would just be a very, very long
list and it would make for a pretty boring show,
but no fascinating history to the language. Don't
speak a word of it, although I don't know how
similar it is to Spanish. Maybe it's sort of like
with Portuguese or some of the Spanish dialects
where it just sounds or Italian or French, where
it sounds similar enough that I could understand
it. All right. We have a tremendous bonus show
for you today from Portland is set to vote on
banning travel from Texas. This would be sort
of a retaliation to the new Texas abortion law.
We'll talk about that on the bonus show. Number
two, a judge has ruled that an Ohio hospital
cannot be forced to give patients ivermectin,
period. And number three, El Salvador has become
sort of the first Bitcoin nation they have now
bought for national as part of their national
reserves, I guess is the word to use. They have
bought I think it's 200 Bitcoin. What does this
mean? What are the pros and cons? Could we see
more countries do it? Is this crazy? Does it make
any sense? We will discuss that on today's bonus
show. How do you access the bonus show? Very
easy. You sign up at join Pakman Dotcom. It's
that simple. You sign up and within 30 seconds
you could be listening to the bonus show. If
you already have an account on Patreon or want to
make one for whatever reason you might prefer it.
You can also access the bonus show by making
a pledge at Patreon dot com The David Pakman
Show of at least five bucks a month. We will
see everybody then or if not on tomorrow's.